First I want to generate a yLow. .nextDouble will give me something between 0
and 1, but I want it to be between 0 and 2, and I definitely want a double.
Because yLow could be anywhere between 0 and 2. Then I'll generate another
double between 0 and 180, and I'll use both of those to calculate yHigh, which
is yLow plus the sin of A in radiance. Now if yHigh is greater than or equal to
2, then I increment the number of hits. But I want to do all of this try as
times, so I'll highlight it all, hit tab to indent, and then wrap it in a for
loop. And I'll need to actually declare hits. Which starts off at 0. All right.
Let's try this. I'm going to try it 30,000 times. 3.13. I guess it's okay. It's
not great. Let's try it again. 300,000. It's a little closer to 3.14. How about
3 million or 30 million? 30 million. This one might take a second but not that
long. 3.141. We're getting much closer now, but it took 30 million flips. And
Pi is actually 3.1415 something or another. So we've only got three digits
correct. I think anyone who tried to do this without a computer would be
flipping needles for their entire life. This method was simply not viable
without a computer.